you
back to sell you are a chairman of the
committee for the prize in economic
sciences can you explain for us in what
way this year's economic price is about
economics oh it's it's I think as roth
laureate said that it's about very
central things in people's lives it's
about how they find a school when
they're young how they go to college how
they maybe get married how that works
and then how they find a job it's about
matching people with other people and
with schools etc but it's just nothing
about finances or money no economics is
not always about money and that's that's
really clear in this year's price
however money can be used sometimes and
there's not necessarily anything wrong
with it but in many cases money cannot
be used such as the case with kidney
transplants I think there's no developed
country where one is allowed to simply
start the market for kidneys and then
all the same we need to do something and
how do we do it well and not even
assignments of students to high schools
are allowed to be paid in some way right
and I think here it's a little bit more
different from country to country
whether you can buy buy a place in a
good school or not but certainly many
countries have very strong restrictions
on what can be done and usually it's
politics and and I think certainly in
the case of Sweden there are very strong
restrictions and that's what people vote
to get so given those rules we have to
think of a smart system
but the whole story started with Lloyd
Shapley quite theoretical works in games
theory and anyhow he used actually a
concrete example in his article as I
understand can you tell us about this
right actually I think it started with
his colleague David gale who asked this
concrete question how should we organize
the college admission process and
because they realized that it was hard
it was a hard problem even
mathematically a really hard problem and
then they together came up with this
solution that was a purely mathematical
solution but often when you do abstract
economic theory you still have to have
very concrete examples and the example
was matching students to schools even
though they had been college in mind so
they worked from from I don't think they
had any idea that it would one day
become well number one put in practice
and number two actually be a Nobel Prize
level contribution so if they were to
about the this work where is the
colleague of sharply David gale
unfortunately died a number of years ago
and he was instrumental in the process
as well so that's just very unfortunate
what was what was the crucial research
in this field that led to the prize
I think it's very clear this year that
you cannot imagine one out one without
the other so first it was his
theoretical work that we were just
talking about but then the practical
side of things was also absolutely
crucial it was when Roth in the eighties
he had studied the gaels Shapley
algorithm but he didn't much believe in
it and as to rally some percent
presented the case here today he
actually was skeptical that it could
work and when he looked at the economic
outcomes in the market for physicians he
realized that actually to his big
surprise it had worked and that was a
revelation that was a true discovery and
then it took off from there I think but
actually students were admitted to
topologies into the high schools a long
time before rods work what is the
difference between then and later well I
think one issue in practice is that you
get better or worse indications that
things don't work it was very clear in
the in the market for us doctors that it
didn't work because people were
participating in the system they
realized that there was a lot of
crowding a lot of people were left
unmatched so the whole thing broke down
but in many cases in practice the the
mechanism doesn't break down it just
doesn't work well and it's not so clear
maybe to the policymakers that that the
kids are unhappy that the schools are
unhappy in that situation so I think you
could certainly have something that
somehow works a little bit but it may
not work very well and I think this this
year's price really makes us think again
in all these contexts do we really have
a good system and now we have the
their system and I hope I made by poor
developed by Alvin rock what are the
limitations of this system what are the
limitations well as so right now I'm
thinking more about the great scope for
for applications but of course there are
limitations I mean why one issue that he
works with and many of his collaborators
is the problem that sometimes schools or
say politicians want to have certain
amount of balancing school between
different types of students say from
different background and he has worked
that into some of the city's school
systems mechanisms but that's a
challenge and they're still working on
it doesn't work perfectly so it's some
things are harder to to put in putting
use than others and I think the sort of
avoiding segregation and so on it's very
important and and that's what they're
working on so we have to put mathematics
in the society sure yeah mathematics
really helps to clarify I mean here it's
clear that if they hadn't thought about
this in terms of mathematics I don't
think we would have been where we are
today did you talk to the Lord's just
before the press conference right after
the Academy makes the formal decision
which happened at roughly eleven thirty
we go and have lunch and during lunch we
we call the laureates and we first call
and Rosen he first didn't answer so we
called again because usually if it's in
the middle of the night you know you you
don't quite react to the phone call but
and they picked up the second time and
actually his first statement was it was
worth waking up for five o'clock in the
morning unfortunately we did not we did
not reach professor Shapley so he's also
on us west coast time and I think he's
sleeping but we're trying as we speak
probably
one is trying to call him he's 89 years
old we hope that both will come to
stockholm in december well it's clear
that the professor roth is coming and I
very much hope that professor Sharpe is
coming too I I hope and I think so but
we we have yet to see we cross our
fingers thank you character cell for
being here with us thank you so much
accion